hey y'all it's andrew couch here and
this is the beginning
of season two of the tidy tuesday series
so i'm gonna be making a few changes
into the actual
series format um first i'm actually
gonna change the frequency of videos
so i'm going to change it to basically
two videos a month
it'll be on a bi-weekly or uh bi-weekly
basis so it'll be like a video
once every other week on tuesday
i'm still going to upload it at 7 pm
central time
and one of the main reasons why i wanted
to reduce the actual
frequency of video content was one i
really didn't want to burn out because
you know now that i'm working full time
i'm constantly coding in r and sql
so i don't want to have to you know
write a lot of our
code on the weekends every week instead
i can kind of like
you know split the actual work on the
weekends and a half
additionally though um i will be uh
making
a few extra videos every now and then um
that won't be
on tuesdays for our scheduled formats
so i think it'd be interesting to do you
know more interviews with people
in the data science community so not
only other data scientists
and you know different fields but also
like people
in uh data science fields that aren't
actual data scientists so like project
managers and stuff like that
um i also wanted to like you know
interview a few professors of mine
and kind of pick their brain about one
teaching teaching r
in college and also r and academics and
also like academic trends and industry
trends
and stuff like that so that won't be
replacing any of the
any of the actual videos um instead
it'll be mostly an addition
um to that type of stuff so
it's still gonna be the same basic
formats but there's gonna be a few
goodies uh sprinkled
every now and then so uh to start off
the actual series
uh i'm gonna kind of show you the actual
repo format so
i split the actual season one and season
two scripts
out um i also have now oops uh
um i also will have like you know the
app
folder data folder scripts folder um and
stuff like that so it's nothing too
crazy
um additionally with the actual scripts
that me
posting now i'm gonna try to include
like a video link um this is like a
random uh
a random uh radar that i was working on
so for example the characters tidy
models
script i'm gonna include the actual
video link of it so
um that's gonna be a little bit easier
when in case if someone you know
comes across my repo or comes off across
the actual scripts
uh and they want to actually kind of do
a walkthrough of the actual um scripts
um that'll be there
so starting out this season i wanted to
do
a video on docker and just like overall
deployment using
um r docker um
when i was actually learning about
docker um i've heard about you know
all these devops systems and
applications like
you know you know docker flask
kubernetes but
they're said a lot but it's always
assumed that you
know what they're actually talking about
and for me i really didn't know you know
what really differentiates all these
application names i know they're very
popular and used in like deployment and
devops
but i know exactly what they actually
did uh so
at a high level docker basically you
know creates a little mini
computer or virtual machine for your
computer or scripts to run on
and the main idea behind it is that you
know when we're running an r
shiny app you know we have to run the
script and then we can access it through
like our browser or interface same with
like a plumber api
we run it on our script and then we can
start accessing it
uh but that kind of doesn't make a lot
of sense if you're you know working a
company and you want to deploy your
scripts
to like on a company wide level right so
it doesn't make sense
you know to have like some laptop uh
plugged in
turned on all the time to basically get
those requests
um instead it makes more sense to have
like kind of like a lean
computer in this case they use like a
linux
system uh and that way you know we can
kind of just have
a computer just made specifically to run
a particular r script
uh so that's what docker basically does
and then kubernetes is kind of like
helps running the back end to help like
load management and stuff like that
so when i was actually learning docker
there were
a lot of resources that weren't very
useful in my own case um some of the you
know docker resources that i used
uh weren't up to date um and just simply
wouldn't even
run uh because i don't really matter
very well
um additionally like the entire docker
image is actually pretty
simple um we already have the rocker
community or the r community with
docker and they create a lot of these
base images for like
r r studio tidy verse shiny etc
and then basically what we have to do is
just like add a little bit more to it
like
you know we add our own apps our scripts
our data and our
libraries so when you actually look at a
docker image that i created
um it seems pretty simple but one of the
issues with it is that
when you're actually learning docker
with as an r user um there's a lot of
these random commands that they kind of
tell you to add
but you really don't know why you're
doing it so it's really hard to debug
um the issues with the actual docker
image the main
resource that i used was statworks.com
and they kind of do a pretty good a
description of how to create your docker
file
uh for a shiny app so as you see is a
very short article
and this was literally the most useful
resource i
i used and it took me about three weeks
of actual research
until i came across this website and it
already worked like in an instant so it
was kind of interesting to see that
that being said i'm going to open up the
season 2 folder
uh i'm going to go to our apps because
we're going to be deploying an app
i have little r shiny deployment folder
and it contains
a r folder which contains our app you
know our modules
our final model um and then our data
and additionally our docker file so one
of the reasons why i
created a little separate folder which
is so we have like all the stuff in
there and it doesn't really inter
um integrate with our other files but
i'll get into it more once i open up
my docker file that i created so when i
was first developing
a docker file i was actually using vs
code
and i think it was kind of a weird way
to approach it because you can actually
create docker files in our studio
so from now on i'll probably just do it
in our
um so here's the actual docker file as
you can see it's a very
short uh docker file you know it seems
pretty simple
and i think it is a very simple thing
but there's a lot of weird headaches
that i ran into with like
was a debian packages and stuff like
that so let's actually go through it
so here's the actual base image that i
imported which is a
shiny image so it installs like the
shiny stuff um this from the
hub.doctor.com from the user rocker
which is the r community who helps
create
docker files for our users then we
actually install the
um libraries for our iclinic system
and as you can see it's kind of
ambiguous we know like xml
you know made with like we know like an
xml file right um we know like sql
uh maria db so it's like a database end
um ssh ssl curl odbc
connection stuff like that but i really
don't know what they're exactly doing
and why we do it
and that came with a lot of problems
because uh when you're looking at
different
you know articles and resources they
kind of install different stuff
even though they're using the same image
and they don't really tell you why
they're doing it um so that was very
annoying and it was kind of frustrating
to actually see
you know how simple these these docker
files are and yet you still run into
issues where you kind of don't know
what's going on
um that probably is uh probably
my own fault too but i think having you
know a nicer
website like the rstudio um tutorials
that they offer
would be useful in the future for the r
community as a whole
um so here's this little command that
actually i kind of update everything
with the system wires after we install
the debian or demon packages
and then we actually go into the more r
specific things so
in this case i installed the packages
required for
um our app so like typers shiny
dashboard actually boost
dc for our tables plot way for our plots
tidy models for our models
gg ridges for one of our plots and tidy
text to actually format one of our
faceted bots
um if you haven't seen the app um you
definitely look at my season one video
um series where i kind of go over the
actual process of creating the actual
models
and actually creating the apps so one
thing that i did
too which i think it makes a little bit
easier um
is i made a directory to a root root app
directory etc
a root directory um and then i copied
the actual folder containing
all of our stuff uh into um the root
folder called
shiny save then expose a connection
uh and then we run the command like r
and we run the shiny run app
which is where our actual app is being
uh housed in
okay um i'm actually gonna go in and
kind of show you
a few things that i changed and why i
didn't explicitly put this doc
file um with my ufc uh sports bank repo
and i kind of have had it where uh it
was just kind of integrating with all
the
existing files um one thing is just
because i use the
the here package a lot um because i
think you
managing directories and working with
directors that are and maybe even
and maybe just because it's windows it's
kind of a hassle
uh so i just kind of use here and it
kind of gives me all the root
directories and stuff like that
uh definitely because i'm pretty lazy
but that actually runs
it for me it ran i ran to a few issues
with directories
uh which is why i made my own directory
in the shiny uh in the docker
file and i also removed the hear package
from the app
uh that way you can actually like kind
of explicitly look for
the models and the modules
okay so when we actually have the um
docker file what we can do is as
you can see i've already built this um
file but we can just build it again so
docker build
dash t and i'll just say what did i call
it again
i'm just i don't have them ufc app
and then dots run it and as you can see
we're in the terminal
so it runs pretty fast just because i've
already built it
um so it you know it runs like commands
it adds all like
uh it kind of adds all the images and
creates the layers and stuff like that
and then we created the file um we also
have to make sure we have docker
installed
and that we have like um and we can kind
of check if
what's going on so right here we have
the ufc app and i can just
do like a run if i really wanted to
um yeah i do run and then we can see it
open there
um and we can actually like open it in
our uh
in our uh what is it our chrome so if we
type in like vocal host 3838
uh since we have it exposed to 38
uh oops what's going on
oh yeah i'm totally up right now uh oh
maybe it's not
um let's see here
see what's going on
oh well i can just uh i just run it
right here so if we look in uh
docker run dash d dash dash rm dash
p or i slash oh yeah dash p and then we
do 38 38
38 38 uh ufc
app
and then i can refresh it just set
oh what the
oh uh which one up there we go
so it's up right now um took a little
bit to load i think one of the things i
can
improve is kind of remove all the excess
data and also kind of optimize the us
ufc dashboard but we can see our
dashboards in our
localhost 3838 and it's running
okay so i'm actually gonna
stop these
okay um one of the things that's
actually pretty useful about
um using these docker files is that it's
pretty easy to share to people
so once you actually create your image
um what i actually did was put it on my
um docker hub and then
oops let's see here we can see our
docker hub and then
if we actually do the public view from
for my actual profile
we can see that we have our ufc app
right here that you can um
grab by just copying this command and
pasting into your command line
which is pretty useful too because that
way you don't have to you know
go and go through and install your
packages and do all that stuff and
recreate your your docker file instead i
already have it right here which will
have
all the stuff for you so that's
basically it for this video
um i know it's pretty a pretty fast
video and there's not really that much
content
um that's because doc files in general
are pretty easy to create
in theory um i think just with the our
community there's not a lot of resources
for us
uh so i think this video will hopefully
help you kind of get a little
starting guideline where you know if you
have a shiny app you can kind of
look at this install your packages copy
your app
and it'll be pretty much good to go for
where you can put it wherever you want
obviously with like plumber and stuff
like that it's gonna be a little bit
different
but um rocker and plumber uh have
a pretty good integration together and
pretty good documentation uh so it's
pretty straightforward
that being said uh i'm i am planning on
making
a few more videos that i've already kind
of pre-planned so i'm going to make a
video
of next week on august in two weeks
technically
um on dimensionality reduction and
machine learning
also i would like to do a video on
geospatial plotting so plotting like you
know
coordinate uh coordinate data so that'll
be pretty interesting
additionally i i am going to do a big
data video
for this season i know i put it off for
season one but i'm definitely gonna do a
season two
uh big data video so i'm looking forward
to that
uh with that being said um i'll see you
guys next time and tidy on